las lágrimas y el terror inundaron la
que iba a ser una mañana normal en la
ciudad de bluevenau un hombre de 25 años
saltó un muro y logró acceder a la
guardería cantiño buen pastor y atacó a
varios menores de Entre cuatro y siete
años con un hacha Posteriormente se
entregó a las autoridades
Cuando llegamos al lugar Confirmamos la
muerte de cuatro menores tres niños y
una niña otros cuatro menores resultaron
heridos uno de ellos En condición seria
y fueron asistidos
el presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
condenó a través de su cuenta de Twitter
los hechos que se presentaron a sólo 10
días de la apuñalamiento registrado en
un colegio de Sao Paulo en donde un
adolescente de 13 años acuchilló a una
profesora causándole la muerte e hirió a
otras cuatro personas no hay mayor dolor
que el de una familia que pierda a sus
hijos o nietos más aún en un acto de
violencia contra niños inocentes e
indefensos mis condolencias y oraciones
a las familias de las víctimas y la
comunidad de bloominado en medio de la
monstruosidad ocurrida en la guardería a
buen pastor
el gobierno del Estado de Santa Catarina
canceló las clases durante dos días y
declaró tres días de luto las
autoridades investigan si el presunto
responsable actuó solo o en compañía al
tiempo que intentan Acceder al teléfono
móvil y el computador del arrestado a su
vez informaron que el hombre ya tiene
antecedentes penales sin revelar por
cuales delitos